what are we doing for that fight you
know I don't want no no go to Frank's
man you got to come to Frank's it's
gonna be in that crowded field
ya know you'll have Pro boxers there
people who've not gonna be yeah that's
the worst thing no I watch at home with
my family come over to Frank I can't
stand it man
one has their two cents and what guys
should be doing and stuff throw the jab
more oh why is he not jabbing yeah when
you fight a guy that you got a fake look
if you come I'm gonna do that don't I
it's the worst you got a fake bang
that's just general [ __ ]
bop bop like you got to go the body more
this that's a little guilt about you
listen when you go to the book
oh so that I can write so my face is
open right you're in the purge too that
doesn't mean you can critique Canelo
Alvarez boxing he boxes dude I want to
just say something to you and look you
in the eye wanna see congratulations
goddamnit you got engaged I'm so happy
for you and I'm I'm emotional hug you in
that way people who it's alright die so
I feel like guys feel like they have to
say girls are more excited yeah well I
said I made you a little video with a
breezy Oakley I wanted your girls
sweating yeah yeah that's what uh but
you know I mean so I wanted to make your
video but yeah I mean I'm not gonna go
hey buddy
congratulations huh yeah it's your dad
it's kinda like it's kind of a room of a
death but it's also not like ah like you
just like I get it Oh with guys it's
different
I've never been a huge believer in
marriage and what it stands right I've
never even known yeah I've never had
like mmm divorce family and I just never
really believed in the structure of
marriage I think having a kid is by far
bigger binding contract than any
government paperwork oh yeah like when
you have a kid I don't care if you hate
each other whatever you're never leaving
a kid's life but you're it's not that
but you and that mother connected for
life
whether you hate each other or not you
are forced to do a mother of your child
not because there's a government
contract so to me that was a bigger deal
but the game changer for me and I've
never really wanted to get married I you
know that I never it's it's strange to
me though the whole structure of it we
were talking about cyclists in this town
of your any problems with cyclists uh
listen thing about cyclists unless
you're getting paid unless you're
competing in an actual Tour de France
why in the [ __ ] are you in the middle of
the road and in all that gear right
unless you've actually qualified for a
legit race don't wear all the spandex
and don't have that bike don't have the
matching helmet you're also [ __ ]
sponsors all over your Jersey you got
your sponge you bought that I bought it
you bought that doing what are you doing
and if you're gonna mean that if you
want to pretend your car not like to get
the lights you would be a car yeah then
follow the car [ __ ] rules I want you
to stop at the stop signs
yeah it stopped at the stop we'll go on
the freeway does it work just for you
when you want
come on the freeway see ya down San
Vicente and Sundays they go down there
all in the gear unless you're a [ __ ]
team if you're I want to talk to goddamn
captain
why are you guys all in the middle of
the road yeah yeah there's always like
70 of them in a group and by the way
there's a champion too the thing of the
hardest men in the world have you ever
tried to open you thought more well by
right no [ __ ] much yeah well mad have
you noticed how they all have no eyes
black a little belly
yeah I just don't know they wear all the
gear [ __ ] you man
is this strange yeah I'll leave out the
weather sponsorship stuff and all yeah
yeah [ __ ] minder web the shoes in the
coffee shop clean let's get Lance
Armstrong on [ __ ] speed dial don't
wear that [ __ ] if I ever wear that stuff
let's just stop being friends I was at
UFC 199 when he lost to Bisping and it
was the night where Ariel got banned it
was like a crazy night and I was at my
buddy Shannon and and then we we got
back somehow to the press conference
which is it's actually crazy if you
remember Bisping came in with beer it
was still Uriah and Dom's trilogy and
that day the the the pre-fight excuse me
the post-fight press
fence was almost like the pre-fight
press Carlos it was crazy and I was
there and dave meltzer was there mark
Romani was earning they're like dude
Ariel God knows what it's like how I
found out it's a crazy night right
really surreal because I'm I'm it's like
everything's being taken down and I'm
just like drunk with my buddy and I'm
like let's just walk around I don't know
and I'm walking in this like random
hallway yeah it was for him at the forum
and we're backstage was like I've never
seen this face we're checking we're
checking it out and in literally as I'm
walking down a hallway just me and my
like UCB buddy Shannon just Dana White
in his whole entourage he's coming and
he's on the phone probably with China or
something cuz like the next day the sale
was announced right so he was sitting on
that information and I finally see him
and I'm like dude and I was like dude
that post I press conference was crazy
and he was like what and then on my back
comes charging Luke Rockhold Dana dude
dude that's [ __ ] [ __ ] man yeah I
need I know who my god dude I need I
need that back I need that one back you
don't understand like like like I oh my
god I need to fight him right now like
I've never seen he's like I need that
rematch you know well because Bisping
was like rubbing it in his face and he
got knocked out and also I think you
know when you go [ __ ] you yeah that's
what happens I mean you talk all that
[ __ ] man but I saw a very emotional Luke
Rockhold and and but he's begging to his
boss and Dana's just doing the like easy
man we'll see what happens it just
happened just you know yeah but Dana's
do I want to see a rematch right away
when the champion is they don't like
doing rematch too many guys immediate
rematch is yeah it's too much so quite
the best part of this story is that Luke
Rockhold knocked out one of my closest
friends really really awfully like I
mean stopped him in a really vicious way
it was Lydon yeah and I don't like how
he talks about Chris just personally
there's of course but but I feel it's
personal and and it is personal again
his phase so what I did is I say well I
grabbed him by the cut dick right and I
would know
no no but he looked at me sorry Scott
did this discount this this story does
not end with so then I stepped on his
toe and ran away he looks at me and he's
grabbing me and he's going right you saw
it you were there you read the post by
press conference like I think right
right me I'm just like yeah yeah yeah
yeah and if your pain is like seeing
like this awkward situation well I don't
even know Luke I've never even met him
yeah and Dane is like get the [ __ ] out
of here for a second go home just like
will real talk another time